[Music]
we are
back
[Music]
after a week
long break thank you shredder give it up
oh we're standing standing up
standing no
[Music]
i think he just wants to know what's
going on
stand and go we're back
uh it's been a week and we took another
week uh uh break why did we take a week
break before uh somebody snitched on us
oh i got banned i got [ __ ] suspended
by dumbass keemstar forgot
yeah well this time was a self-imposed
suspension
uh because of you know who about you
know what i think everybody knows what
happened right
there people in the chat who know who
don't know why we took a week break
um well
don't surprise me keep an eye on maybe
there are maybe
i guess
yeah you know what
let me open the live stream yeah i wish
i could say that i came back rested and
well
but i feel tired as a mother
theodore's was like had the sniffles
last night
and um he just didn't sleep so he was in
the bed tossing and turning and waking
up every hour
and uh
i'm reading the chat yeah so i guess
some people don't know it makes sense
some people wouldn't know
you would assume everybody would know
but some people maybe you just watch the
channel and aren't following everything
that happens on twitter some people have
lives some people have lives
exactly i i i don't give our fans enough
credit
by the way can we reflect that i am
indeed the hairline king
i mean say what you will about my
physical appearance about anything and i
will
yeah and people do
and i accept all that but if i'm going
to accept all that i need to everybody
to admit that i am the indus undisputed
hairline king without a doubt without a
doubt
that's all i've got it's all i've got
give it to me i am sincerely jealous
it's true it's true me too
anthony fantano's got the best teeth in
the game ethan's got the best hairline
in the game yeah and and hairline's not
something that you know people even talk
about
and it's not something i was really
aware of until
i guess about when i was like 25 people
started commenting on my hairline
and i didn't know what that meant really
to be honest but but now i do
you you got a pretty rocking widow's
peak too
thank you zach yeah
is that a positive yeah
the widow's peak is very dominant it
does i wonder if it's receded a little
bit because i wonder if it was more
filled in before i don't know
it's rocking it's sexy it's hot the
hairline king everybody thank you zach
thank you
yeah so
oh this episode by the way ryan
kavanaugh take note
this episode is brought to you by
curology hello fresh me undies policy
genius and raycon yes that's five ads
ryan kavanagh suck my [ __ ]
tiny jewish [ __ ]
hi i'm dick tip
end of story
ryan marvel at my hairline after sucking
my tiny jewish [ __ ]
yeah so i went offline because of uh
miss voldemort
now i'm not afraid of saying her name
don't give her i
it's such a stupid situation with this
girl because once again she continues to
lie and back me into a corner to the
point where i have to say something
because i if you let this girl get one
lie off on you she's gonna build a whole
god she's gonna write the whole bible on
you based on one lie all of a sudden
you've got genesis you've got the new
testament you've got the old testament
and she wrote a whole story about you
that's not true based on one line he
takes that five percent so that's not
what i'm down for
you know
but yeah she trish has been getting a
lot of backlash for various things
that has nothing to do with
me
or any of us
and she's blaming us it's really weird
anyway she leaked a bunch of text
messages of us having a conversation and
it just turned it spiraled into
all this madness and we just said you
know what we're going to take a week off
so that's it that's the story
there's like a bajillion drama videos
about it if you guys want
to catch up
like it was up to me i would talk more
about it but uh
i'm respecting uh other people's wishes
if it was up to me i'd have plenty to
say about it yeah
i'd have plenty plenty plenty to say
what percentage more would i have to say
about it zach hmm
percent
right
more than that
[Laughter]
five percent
[Laughter]
joe rogan how much more would i want to
talk about it
five percent difference is astronomical
right yeah five percent more at least
five percent means everything at least
yeah
so
i wish i could say more guys i really do
it's not fair
it's not fair that i can't say more
you know
life life is unfair like uh like malcolm
always said
malcolm in the middle
life isn't fair malcolm used to always
say that the theme song
oh
okay until you met malcolm x yeah
malcolm x i believe that he probably
said that too he would probably
agree with that statement yeah
all malcolm's really ryan kavanaugh
after his fight
whoa
yeah i know that was from the gods above
dude they were
right kavanagh of triller had a boxing a
match with two old [ __ ] who were like
seven years old and donald trump
officiated it and it [ __ ] was a huge
financial failure oh it's so flipped
reportedly reportedly a huge financial
failure
you're not poor what do i know i'm not
like god
don't have omniscient awareness
something like that
but it was reportedly a huge financial
flop and of course it was
okay since we're just speaking of
wearing kavanaugh really fast do you
have that comment of him accusing me of
leaving every single hate comment
where is that i want to show that
yeah yeah i got it yeah ryan kavanagh
apparently has been responding
to hate comments
saying i know it's you ethan as if i
don't have better [ __ ] to do like play
final fantasy 14
such a boomer comment it really is
[Laughter]
here it is thank you cam oh it's so
awkward yeah so this guy is trying to
like take the internet by storm
he literally said by the way i saw him
say in a in a
in his youtube channel with two
subscribers actually [ __ ] let's just
go down the right kavanagh rival i don't
give a [ __ ]
well we have the clip from this morning
too
i screen recorded what happened this
morning he was on a live it was on the
live
good stuff well i screen recorded a
chunk of it where he was talking about
his event and the guy was asking him if
the numbers were real and yadda yadda
but the most important thing is the live
chat
yeah that's why
that's why i screen recorded it instead
of just
because
live chat is [ __ ] amazing and there's
some people in there that they know what
flip means so they're like what is flip
what's going on what's what you mean
flip flop just flipped
[Laughter]
flip means flipped
so rank kevin has a channel somebody
discovered with like two subscribers
anyway it's really i said nothing oh
here it is three subscribers is this
really his [ __ ] channel bro oh my god
this [ __ ] really out here with
three subscribers
now how do we know this is his real
channel cam didn't you just like it
links to his real [ __ ] right
yeah selfie videos right
this has to be his channel
yeah so he goes we're gonna break the
internet
with this sort of [ __ ]
over 48 hours actually okay you want to
know why this guy's suing me and why
he's so hurt i'll tell you take one
guess i'll tell you right now it's so
obvious is it his hair this is [ __ ]
it
they hate me for my hairline think about
everyone that hates me keemstar hairline
airline who else name another person
doesn't like me
logan paul airline mike magelick
hairline
king kong jake paul blocked on twitter
hairline
david
david i don't think david hates me i
wouldn't say that
i'm pretty sure he [ __ ] hates
how could he not it may be that he hates
me but i won't put that on him he's
never come after me right that's true
that's true
but hairline
look at this weak ass hair blanks
blanks has literally
his hairline is evaporating like the
rising oceans bro
from the middle well if the oceans are
rising then there's more water yeah so
so his
his baldness is the ocean right right
okay it's overtaken the land is his hair
okay i'm infinitely smarter than you and
um infinitely more successful than you
so many people dislike me blank my
hairline's pretty bad and and and i love
you so yeah yeah it's not a universal
thing thank you thank you for saying you
love me i love you too by the way
um so anyway uh
here is har uh sorry i was gonna say
harvey weinstein
here's ryan kavanagh
hyping up his fight last 24 hours or 48
hours actually we have
you see how he's doing his hairline
thing like he's got first time ever
moved an entire boxing event the same
week
states so we moved from california to
florida we changed our opponent from
oscar de la hoya to holyfield
we brought donald trump
whoa whoa whoa what hey
i mean they were accused of fraud for
lying about
well apparently the fight wasn't
sanctioned even though they advertised
it as being sanctioned which
yes that that seems like
a fraud well that's not i thought it
would be false advertising yeah in this
case but it's hard to know the
difference sometimes senior in to
commentate
first time ever pres president united
states will be commentating a fight live
at this
part um
donald trump
came from high above
and commentated a [ __ ] fight but bro
i wish we could watch
i didn't i haven't seen any of the
actual fight in his commentary but there
was that i guess it was the weigh-in or
a press conference beforehand and they
had trump call in and he was just like
this disembodied voice oh he wasn't
there he wasn't there oh my god they
just had him call in we like to troll
and he's just rambling on and on listen
uh the fight is going to be tremendous
but i have to tell you the the the votes
they were stolen like he started yeah
it's just going to be talking about the
election i
i think he he brought it up at one point
but just like kind of is like his fight
just like the election let me tell you
fraudulent votes but yeah obviously
we're avoiding showing any uh
footage from the trail
honestly i gotta stand by my principles
i think it's fair use i don't mind
showing it oh you think you could sue me
for this one let's see i mean it's not
copyrighted and
nobody could possibly say this isn't
transformative i've criticized his
hairline look at the like ratio even
before we got here yeah i didn't know 67
views
is this guy that caused your thing is
flipped ryan you're handling oh no wait
someone said is this the guy that caused
the metoo movement
i'm not sure
oh oh they're talking about harvey ryan
your hairline is flipped it's so awkward
35 seconds ago simon simon
what are you doing simon your hairline
is flipped it's so awkward
nothing wrong with it listen i am
beautiful and i love all hairlines all
hairlines are beautiful but
i'm just
a theory and we got 50 cent
to
commentate a separate commentating um
yeah i think this is pretty much the
craziest thing we've ever done that's
anything you've ever heard of in in
the world of boxes
we're doing it so
wish us luck saturday
i think we could break the internet
they're gonna break the internet
the only reason ryan cavanaugh's
breaking is the internet is because he
actually doesn't know how to use a modem
you know what i mean
this guy's act literally breaks the
internet in his home
this guy's on the phone with aol trying
to get uh find out why his dial-up's not
working oh it's so awkward these cables
are i think we could break the internet
yeah i think it could break the internet
ryan
anyway here's the comment that started
this all somebody said you look like
you're battling multiple skin conditions
listen i don't know uh if that's a valid
cr it's not a valid criticism
the fact that he's battling skin
conditions isn't a slight against him
you know
anyway he responds why are you using a
fake account ethan
anyone can see it's a troll account
really quite desperate
okay boomer
[Music]
ryan really thinks that every main com
electrician actually
they have that in common
every main comment they get on the
internet is just me
[Music]
why don't you try to subpoena scorpio
private no i mean no shade of scorpio
private yeah why don't you try to sue
her find out this user sue them unless
we could do some discovery
you know
[Music]
i see people saying that i was wrong
about uh trump not being there to be
clear i was talking about the press
conference not the actual yeah i thought
he was there him oh yeah he was there i
remember seeing them yeah i wasn't
talking about the event i i like i said
i haven't i didn't see the event i mean
you know who was not paying for that
[ __ ]
dawn jr oh both the boys dawn [ __ ]
the bruiser boys wow
he comes free with his daddy you don't
have to pay for that one
yeah so that's that
watching my algorithms get crushed
and uh so shout out to the fam
right shout out to his family
yeah
oh man
here's something really cool
what else happened during the breakup oh
yeah let's give a shout out to the call
number
1808 hot meme you got it
announcement to all of our viewers i
know there's been a lot of kickback on
the calls i mean they're very hit or
miss but let's be honest they're more
missed than hit
people just remember the bad ones we've
had we've had plenty of good ones
yeah
we have but anyways go on listen we have
a new system here we have a system that
i think is going to make it all better
we have in our possession not me because
i'm the good guy
all the crew members have a button you
guys remember the gong show you hit the
gong or or american uh talent or
whatever the [ __ ] factor yeah x factor
so if the call is going sideways or it's
boring
or whatever
any of these guys go ahead ab give it
give us a sample
you see that [ __ ]
why does it play the godfather sound
that is so odd listen wait you're right
what is that
is that what on earth did you do i'm not
playing anything i don't know no no but
in this in the sound bite itself in the
x somebody put the godfather
you don't hear that yeah i hear it i
hear it yeah zach you you better be the
one that hear it you're the sound that's
that is extremely odd i don't know why
it's like that
you know what i think probably happened
is i think it's from our among us video
zack might have pulled it from that yeah
there's godfather music in that why
would you pull it from our video no no i
have the sound bite because this is one
i play this one i said can't
i don't know do you have it trimmed in
your system so that it doesn't play the
very end of the clip
no it's playing the godfather i don't
know i can't
you gotta you can pull a clean sound
can't you i i thought it was clean i
apologize i don't know why it's like
that
shame play the godfather sounds at no no
the real one
zack
you were the chosen one
you were supposed to bring
balance and you come into my house on
this beautiful monday after one week off
and you and you [ __ ] up the x sound zack
you break up my heart
you put in the godfather sound into the
x and you do this to me on a monday
ah that's a puzzle
[Music]
and now
we have to take calls and listen to the
godfather eight
[Music]
let's start the music over zach
[Music]
dan dan you buzzing me on my own show on
a monday
i know it was you then
you breaking my heart people are saying
they like it i don't know maybe we could
leave it
it's not a matter of like this just
doesn't make sense right
[Music]
we're trying to run a show here not just
have things going off willy-nilly
oh we have kavakim
how do you call this guy kavakim
that seems kev
kimeno cavstar
cavstar
yeah that's good
this is uh
yeah a two men combined the two men who
are most jealous of my hairlines
combined into one person
so that's exciting so what do you guys
think i mean i think that would make it
more fun it'd be like hey you should go
inside was like hey i gotta need some
advice about something that nobody cares
about and then like i said well peace
and love damn right i'm like sorry well
so and then zach can you
get a soundbite of a toilet flushing oh
sure so then when zach or when somebody
hits it man and then
sure i can do that turning into the tom
leica show
um so is the rule just one person i feel
like
at least two yeah yeah two people need
to uh like there's a nomination and a
second i agree yeah
so there you go three majority that's a
lot of but that's a lot of buzzing yeah
i think two
so just know if you call in
with peace of love
we love you for calling in and sharing
no hate
but
not everybody you know sometimes you
might get buzzed
it's not personal okay we got to keep it
moving
guppy
you want to try one real fast
let's see
yeah we got our buzzers ready
and you guys be don't you know don't be
coy
because the show balances on you guys
now
oh i will no problem good and it's great
because i don't want to be that because
like if i'm like hey listen you know
thanks for calling nobody gives a [ __ ]
and then people go ethan's such an
[ __ ]
so this is a good
all right what do we got
wants to talk about the way people on
the road are driving these days
raphael that seems like a good test of
the buzzer right because this could go
sideways fast yeah
all right raphael
raphael
you're going to be the first to test the
buzzer and i have to tell you with peace
and love
the topic does not sound interesting
that's that's fair i can understand that
i i just need to get something off my
chest all right roundabouts
are very simple all right the inside
lane goes straight and left the outside
lane goes straight and right there's
like 30 000 car crashes every single day
because people try to take a left in the
right lane with peace and love that's
all i got for you
it's just such a simple rule
where are you driving that there's
roundabouts all over the place that's
you got buzzed by abs
they started putting them all across the
midwest okay and just nobody knows how
to use them but why do you why do you
want to why do you why do you want to
share that with us
uh it's less than i want to share it
with you and it's more that i want to
share with all the listeners so that
then they can tell their parents to
learn how to drive again
what do you think our our listeners
don't drive
no i think our listeners drive your
listeners not ourselves you think the
older
the boomers the boomers
the bombers the boomers
need to hear this and the best way for
the boomers to hear this is from people
who are related to them and your podcast
is the perfect group of people to
explain to their characters so we need
roundabouts need to be respected okay
okay so we need the boomers to figure
out the roundabouts now
yes sooner rather than later i mean
there's a lack of cars as it is nobody
wants to get an offender bender right
now it's too expensive
thank you very much hey boomer you made
it through the call
appreciate you raphael thank you i'm a
huge fan thank you so much i appreciate
you too i love you all right take care
we love you you surprised great love
peace of love
very nervous
have a great
all right hey hey av cut but baby cut
him off early i was i was right on the
edge but i was
it was so
odd of a topic it was succinct yeah and
i appreciate it he really didn't ramble
he just he got to a point right away so
i mean maybe you weren't feeling it huh
i guess i'm gonna be the only real one
here
i i would like i said i was about to
buzz him well what about zach and and
ian they also have buzzers yeah
i won't buzz a psa
just in general general rule of years
yeah
didn't know that
i want to test it i want to keep testing
this
uh her parents are leaving everything in
their well to her and not her other
siblings
seems like a long conversation i'm sure
i'm ready for that yeah i could help
speed it up
me too
no i'm not going to take it i know where
that one's going
i'll do us all a favor
okay so here's some exciting um
news
your
top
mommy
oh we found out the gender by the way
i'm not going to say it today i'm going
to say it on friday with elo but we
found out the gender of our baby
turns out it's human
well we don't know that yet oh okay
so uh uh authority magazine just dropped
an article on you though check it out
authority
whoa what's a medium.com medium.com what
are they the authority on
[ __ ] badass
entrepreneurs right okay
everything
power women finally some acknowledgement
for a power woman
gila klein teddy fresh is on to
successfully navigate work
love and life as a powerful woman oh
that's badass oh and this by the way
this jacket is not out yet but that is
teddy fresh that's cool as [ __ ] yeah
yeah check this out it's a whole long
interview i'll check it damn so long as
hell
if you guys want to
read it um medium
dot com i mean i don't even know how
edium.com authority dash magazine slash
power dash women yeah you look just i
guess type power women eli klein and
google i don't know
here i'll read an excerpt be flexible
example we open our business and then a
global pandemic occurred we had to stay
flexible and nimble with a willingness
to bend without compromising our values
it sounds like a real authority on the
topic
authority yeah that's pretty cool i like
i just love when
my thing about ela
is that when you talk about
feminism
i feel like ela is like the perfect
embodiment of this strong independent
woman but the thing is like when there's
conversations about
these feminist or strong women icons
everybody
everybody ignores her because she
doesn't like
she doesn't get on a high horse so she
doesn't talk about it she doesn't like
build she doesn't have a whole platform
on being a feminist and that's fine for
people that do but i feel like people
overlook her because
you know for her it's about showing her
work and what she who she is and living
it
and um
i feel like a lot of times she gets
overlooked because she doesn't
you know make such a big deal out of it
so it's not does that make sense yeah
well said yeah thank you she's not
constantly preaching
there's nothing wrong with that
you know there are issues
but
anyway it's nice to see her getting some
recognition
thank you yeah somebody else pointed
this out if you type eloquent if you
search ela cline
it says
i saw someone's result said wife of el
of ethan cline i think it's on it's
formatted oh no it does
yeah ethan klein's wife yeah i was like
what the [ __ ] yeah let me show you you
should say
if anything it should be the other way
around
ethan klein's wife excuse me
that's pretty whack
i'm pretty sure she's got more
more accomplishments than that
ceo
half of h3h3
right she's the h ceo entrepreneur
icon
yeah ledge
hell yes
carer
this is what you care
yeah exactly care
um
legend
i don't know if i write that
so
there's that
i have someone to say real fast
oh gassy
oh jesus
that's not what i wanted to say okay
uh major restock
teddy fresh happened during the break
some classic pieces are back including
all the basics
and every color you would love
the hoodies the zips the pants the
shorts the skirts some women's classics
like women's crop terry polo work work
work work it
you know what it is what is it
you know don't ask
uh this oh this is sold out sorry guys
women's gingham
knit jacquard cardigan what the [ __ ]
ladies
head on over to teddyfresh.com
peep the restocks
see if there's anything you like thank
you thank you peace and love peace and
love this is a serious message
everybody watching
also this thursday smokey's coming out
people are loving this model we used
it's getting like crazy amount of likes
yeah so this is our smoky drop that's
coming out this thursday
he's pretty cool right yeah it wasn't
what i expected at all when you said
that he's like super
he's such a [ __ ] cool old guy he's
like so fit
silver fox dude he's like so slender but
like in a healthy way you know he must
surf surf or something he's like super
fit
that's hot yeah here's the um
you can't really see the details but
this
this hoodie is really cool
and obviously
a portion goes to protect or goes to the
wildlife
services i forget the name of the but
it's a good cause as well
there you have it thank you thank you
thank you thank you all right let's
debate
oh i there's a do i want to watch chet
hanks um
uh andrew from channel 5. we were
talking about it earlier uh i think it's
only on his available on his page
and i talked to him he said it's
dropping today on youtube oh oh i
checked right before the show let me
check right now again maybe it's maybe
it's out now yeah so i was i was
thinking we could watch that together
psych oh it's not out yet damn yeah yeah
uh
andrew from channel 5 made
a chet hanks
documentary so i wanted to watch the
whole thing
well hopefully it drops while we're live
pussycloth
all right you guys tell me this when i
saw this james charles did a tick tock
where he falls this is the original one
of james charles falling and this
[ __ ] bounces
bro made it out of line we have the
sweaters in hand cardio from beyonce
[Music]
we can't hear that
jingle bell is jingle bells copyrighted
uh
it's probably public domain but the
specific recording might be yeah they're
like we got the bells in that spot we
own your video yeah
yeah so james ate [ __ ] and bounced like
a damn
right this is the old one though to be
clear this one's real obviously yeah but
he dropped the new falling vid
that to me is here i'm watching me [ __ ]
one more time
okay you fell cool not that serious
jesus
you know
i told you he was tripping out
so here he is falling to me it's like so
obviously fake i don't know how you
who believes this is real dan didn't you
say you think it's real well somebody
shared it and i thought it was funny but
maybe it's not real let me see it again
the way he falls it's so obvious the
reaction of the people in the background
made me think it was maybe real
oh i didn't maybe i didn't even hear the
audio
that's a sound bite
isn't it
what no it sounds like a soundbite
i hate it though i think it's real i
mean his wig fell off i mean that's a
lot of work to put into that makeup and
that look
[Laughter]
i think it's
fake
he's still human after everything you
guys after everything um here
i didn't fall that bad anyway like face
first eh
maybe it's wearing heels yeah he was and
yeah
that's true the heels will get you yeah
so
youtube this past weekend implemented
polls directly in the chat and i was
[ __ ] around with it earlier and it
works really well
[Music]
what the hell is this it's uh
this is our cursed account you said
right then
uh it's yours it's the one from
white trash thirsty tick tock
so uh what i'm asking the community
right now
is the james ball real it's real it's
fake all right vote now everybody okay
cool
oh damn
are you just i'm scrolling through the
stick talk for you now yeah since i'm
here why not i think the audience made
it down for all the cute guys out there
sexy cute guys hi
my name is ken
um this is going to be on tick tock for
all the cute guys out there sexy cute
guys oh
i think some of you guys on there guys
will milk shirt on you oh
[Music]
hi that's for that my name is cam i'm
sure they'll see this
um this is gonna be on tick tock for all
the cute guys out already
already all right so far
uh we're up to eight thousand votes it's
about sixty percent real forty percent
fake it seems to be okay i'll be you
know
landing right around there
60 40. when i heard it i didn't hear
sound okay
and i didn't see all the hubbub with
these people
i still think it's a good chance it was
fake
like they could have had uh they could
have had like a mattress or something
soft at the foot well certainly they
could have faked it yeah but i don't
know
the audio made me feel like it was
organic but
but it's pretty closely split we're up
to ten thousand votes it's still 60 40.
that seems to be where it's it's gonna
land i think it's real all right
oh
okay wait wait wait wait um interesting
i just saw that too we have a caller
this can't be real we we do we are at
break time i don't know if you want to
do that first because this could take us
do the call first okay
okay so
this according this can't be real
this can't be real
according to this person ollie
her
she saw zach poop on the grass
and she says
she doesn't watch the show the neighbor
does and told her
to call zach what do you think you think
this is real i'd i'd
let's see what uh they gonna say are you
gonna be embarrassed if this sounds real
no not at all i'm proud of my dump
that's [ __ ] disturbed
you should be ashamed sometimes you
should definitely not feel good about it
i can't wait but i'll i'll tell you you
gotta ask them if they know the city and
the town it was in okay
people are going to dox themselves well
no we need to do that off the air wait
city and town or just where exactly
where exactly the city in
name the street or no no no no no no the
city in olly are you there
yes i am okay hold up
hold on one sec we're trying to verify
we're trying to figure out how to verify
your identity first before you even try
to [ __ ] me here
so hold on hold on
we can say the city the city yeah
that's not a documentary okay is a city
of like a bajillion people okay okay all
right what city did you see zach [ __ ]
in what shitty did i see what yes what
[ __ ] what city what city did it occur in
without getting too specific but just
where where did this happen
i will say i don't feel comfortable
excuse me zach i did not see you poop i
know that i walked out the next day
today
i i can't even entertain until you can
prove
[Music]
first off if you saw the picture of my
dump there was no corn in it second off
what city was it in
what city what city in california
[Music]
bye ollie you're getting dumped by your
thank you though thank you for trying
but we got you
good effort good effort that was good we
got to the bottom of it that was fraud
what would you call that job
jaw would say
i would call that a fraud thank you
well at least we got to we we click
quickly go to the bottom yeah yeah
all right
we got to do some ads all right let's
thank our swamp we're going to break
them up today right we have too many
ryan cavanaugh so we're gonna do
we're gonna do a few
right now well ryan's watching and he's
counting my money because he doesn't
have any right yeah he's like
five ads today
i'm gonna take that
my man five ads
dude you know what's crazy about ryan
cavanaugh he's gonna stiff the president
because that [ __ ] is going
bankrupt
and he's going to literally stiff donald
trump
like straight up
austin mcbroom [ __ ] dude
yeah i was thinking austin might be able
to give ryan some pointers on how to uh
do a bankruptcy
although to be fair ryan has plenty of
experience with bankruptcy
anyway
[Music]
oh i have a meme from a yeah exactly
this is what i was thinking of
ryan's look ryan when he sees we have uh
five sponsors
um
[Music]
taking that
all right back with the music
today thank you curology
i love curology
geology
you get the skin care that you deserve
from
dermatologist organizations
excuse me they're gonna customize a
formula for you specifically for your
skin type and here's how it works you
take a photo of your skin
you answer a questionnaire and you send
it back
they hook you up with a uh derm licensed
dermatology provider
and get you a formula specifically made
for your skin here's what they this is
what i got i got the wash which is
gentle cleansing it doesn't like strip
your skin of oil which i love
then you put on the formula
and then you put on the moisturizer and
you're good it's a perfect three
process
um
there's basically they can address all
kinds of skin issues for example
uh
let me find what they wrote here about
it
customizes prescription with reactive
ingredients picked for you to help
tackle your skin care needs whether you
may be trying to take control of acne
fine lines dark spots or even occasional
breakouts or clogged pores
boom that's what they're on
i love it you know i've got a skin care
routine that i love thanks to curology
you don't have to fricks around with
going to a dermatologist such a pain in
the ass expensive is time consuming you
want to hear some uh positive feedback
from the chat that uses curology i use
curology every day and it's wonderful
says kyla thank you yeah
no i genuinely miranda says curology
actually works really well yes i love to
hear that because i actually do love
this product and i it's i actually think
it's such a great service because
yeah
well that's great thank you for sharing
that dan
you can start using curology and go on a
curology journey just like i am with a
three free 30-day trial at curology.com
h3 if you pre
if prescribed just pay five dollars for
shipping and handling
that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g
dot com h3 to unlock your free
30-day trial please refer to our medical
team and that's not for you guys just
like that
thank you curology
well it's in yellow and i usually you
know they gotta work on them
maybe a different color
hello fresh hello fresh hello fresh
hello fresh
what is hello fresh
what is it do you love cooking
i do
i do too i'll tell you what i don't love
going to the store
measuring [ __ ] out
buying a [ __ ] 10 pounds of celery
because you want need one stick
driving back from the store all this
[ __ ]
you know sometimes the worst part of
cooking deciding what to cook hellofresh
sends you a shipment and a refrigerated
box to your door
with all of the pre-measured ingredients
fresh beautiful ingredients
and the recipe that is so simple to
follow it's a no-brainer you're going to
be cooking delicious nutritious home
meals for you and your family
it's the fun way it's affordable
that's why it's america's number one
meal kit
fall is busy but hello fresh recipes
save you time you'd otherwise spend
meal planning shopping and chopping
no [ __ ] chopping
so you can get back the time that
matters
hello fresh family friendly menu is a
big win for back to school season with
easy delicious recipes for drama-free
dinners
yeah i love it you know
i've used it the guys have used it it's
just a fun good wholesome meal
but none of the friggin [ __ ] bruh
this is uh for maybe the other day okay
you're gonna cook it i mean what the
[ __ ] is this well yeah so
you got marty's job this is what how it
looks when it comes with everything all
portioned out for you everything and
then he made oh [ __ ]
veggie quesadilla pretty good
center cut
not this time oh that's it that's all we
got it how was it it was really good
nice it was it was a good bonding
experience too just cooking together and
very convenient
so you just took a picture you just took
a photo of the tortilla
so that was pretty good
yeah well all the ingredients are in
there i would assume i would have liked
to have seen
the inside
noted yeah well here
just there you go that's what was inside
your imagination
i'll use my
imagination
did you put the plastic inside or did
you throw that out no plastic throughout
the plastic okay stand at home i don't
know what was inside right i have to use
my imagination got it
now it's a lot of fun it's delicious
it's nutritious and actually it ends up
being more affordable than just going
out and buying the groceries yourself
you know
so go to hellofresh.com h3tv14 and use
code h3 tv 14 for up to 14 free meals
including free shipping remember that's
h
that's hellofresh.com
h3tv14
use code h314 tv14
it's in the description
anyway
hello fresh america's number one meal
kit thank you thank you peace and love
oh all right this one more here guys
me undies me undies me honey it's soft
it's breathable
your fat ass is gonna fit nice and snug
and these undies because let's face it
we're all growing up we're all getting
older there's no reason for us to be
loving around and our the same freaking
underwear we've been wearing since like
this eighth grade this disinter
disintegrating you have holes in your
underwear i can see your [ __ ] through
your underwear because there's a giant
hole it's embarrassing you can go on a
date you're gonna go over your your
significant other's house with tears in
your underwear it's outrageous time to
upgrade
you know and let me tell you whether
you're out oh okay this is uh whether
you're out running a killer or being
abducted by aliens this halloween be
comfortable by the fact that your undies
are sustainable and the softest is town
mandy's are made from natural fiber
sourced from beechwood trees making
their micro mobile modal fabrics soft
breathable and dangerously cozy get your
spooky season up
and haunting with five new prints eyes
on you my boo trick and treat lazy bones
and lazy pumpkins available in undies
bralettes socks and loungewears and
sizes extra small through 4xl there are
a lot of options to consider but make a
decision quickly because there's
somebody right behind you
that's so cute
if there was someone right behind me i'm
buying underwear because at least to my
interest
for my listeners me undies uh any first
time purchase you get 15 off and free
shipping what mandy's has a promise
if you're not satisfied with any product
for any reason you can return your order
for a full refund within 45 days man
that's pretty good it's risk-free 15 off
come on and free shipping get your
percent off your first order free
shipping and 100
satisfaction guaranteed go to
meundies.com h3tv that's mendes.com h3tv
thank you thank you thank you thank you
we're done
[Music]
thank you guys
[Music]
yeah
so
what a bop what else we got here um
i've uh been informed by the chat that
the chet hanks documentary was posted
just a few moments ago should we watch
it i'm sorry i'm still not seeing it
well then why did the chat lie to me
it's possible sometimes it takes a few
minutes to show up on the video feed
okay fair enough channel page fair
enough got it so we'll check back there
in a moment yeah i think that'd be fun
to watch right
i mean chet's a f you know friend of the
show
absolutely as as any of the show
unfortunately it seems to be going that
way isn't it
since he's
threatened you with physical harm on
multiple occasions now
and blocked me
that's rough
yeah
that is rough
oh man you want to watch uh
this was so funny
people
my mom's on tick tock now
and she has no [ __ ] idea
i mean she's doing pretty good managing
it herself i mean it took her a minute
to get it but this comment exchange
reminds what like mega boomer [ __ ] bruh
[ __ ] baby now someone says donna can we
get a what i eat in a day and she just
said question mark
and then someone said
they responded like you show you
what you have for breakfast lunch dinner
snacks and stuff
it seems like pretty straightforward
right i mean it's a tick tock thing but
anyway my mom's response monarchs eat as
much as 200 leaves
before they turn into chrysalis which is
a two-week period of time so
she's just a monarch fact bot at this
point i know yeah basically
her account's pretty great though we'll
see
shout out to my mom
they're still out there
i believe ela's in the chat
no way
oh yeah yeah she said hi ethan and crew
and everyone wait how do you see it it's
going so fast i just saw the moderator
it's just a little bit up if you scroll
up either did you see we talked about
your article
and how you're strong beautiful
independent woman who don't need no man
but chooses to be with one
elo we've been good if you're checking
on us
i only mentioned trisha
we're talking about lawsuits and this
and
i don't like it oh [ __ ]
[Music]
he was in the chat okay let me sit up
straight
pull together pull together man
get back on the rails ethan
okay good good point
it's not wednesday yeah um
yeah so ryan cavanaugh was
on this uh
he was on some kind of
live it was an mma
talk show it was live on youtube and you
know what cav
you might be a big shot in hollywood but
on youtube you ain't [ __ ] [ __ ] but a
scoundrel and a [ __ ] let me guess let
me guess ryan
you think that i'm sitting there
multi-computering with a hundred
different accounts throwing tomatoes at
your ass were these all me too [ __ ]
there will be knockouts
it just won't go by the way i didn't
even know this was a thing when i read
people saying oh it was an exhibition we
didn't call this out we didn't send
people here this is just while the
internet we just discovered it yeah this
is how the internet feels about ryan cav
kev kavanaugh
this has so many different work terms to
it right and what it can mean but it had
every piece of a pro fight with the
exception is it didn't go into box rack
god is audio's such [ __ ] there have been
some reports about the business it did
the buys are those accurate dan rayfield
reporters it seems like the people who
are who don't know like even the memes
like trailers flip just hate him because
he's a terrible promoter and
ruining boxing yeah like i know the
actual mma audience in this hate him
they seem to hate him even more
this is the dumbest explanation i can't
stand this guy had to leave a dislike
ryan
it's all flipped
brian ryan ryan
if you were just mad about my hairline
why don't you just go see a doctor bro
you got enough money to get a transplant
you don't have to go sue me and do all
this
150 k are you able to confirm or deny
well first of all i can tell you is i
understand this he says this dude is as
truthful as a bottle of ketchup does
anyone know what that oh i don't get it
okay
ask him about the allegations in court
documents true if he's right he's a
soothsayer because as i think most
people in this business know you don't
get your he's super charismatic
also like he's using zoom's like auto
blur out thing but like why is that
whole frame is his zoom feed why is he
so tiny
you think if you're going on a show you
at least get good audio it shows how
much look how little respect he has for
anyone else trying to think but nothing
happens guy ran a giant hollywood
production company with like oscar
winning movies for years well and now
he's running on social media
a platform right it's like
just pretend you're on your dumb ass app
it would turn up
for a while it's antiquated so we don't
even know
um within call it a stone's throw of
what up
not good it's not a good response and
and frankly
oh here's another thing sorry i'm gonna
get off ryan kavanaugh soon but there
was just a lot of stuff that came up
when the week we were gone
oh this is the same show
yeah oh yeah this is a pretty big
youtube channel and has over a million
subs
so he's all about mma and stuff yeah
well let me give him a shout out the mh
the mma hour
i think that's probably good
yeah so um shout out to him
but jake paul
i'll say to his credit
uh called it like he saw it
it i just saw it happen when you
whenever you when you full screen it it
mutes it i have no idea why it does oh
weird bruh
it's a 30 million dollar bet from
triller and and vitor after he was kind
of dismissing you all week saying you're
the disney guy and all this stuff and
then they go and say stop running
thanksgiving one year anniversary of the
first show let's go 30 million winner
take all did that surprise you or did
you think that something like that was
coming
i i honestly didn't think that was
coming
um and
it's surprising because it's like let's
be honest we know that they don't have
that money to put up so
it's smart on their end because
they get the clout now we're talking
about trailer now we're talking about
detour so you know that's that's how
this industry works right uh but
we we know that they don't have that
money you know and
and so it's very outlandish for them to
say that
um
if they
you know show proof of funds and put the
money into a bank account it'd be a
whole different story but we've worked
with them and we we know that they don't
have that much money there you go
i worked with them and i know he's broke
just wait till this fight just wait till
he has to pay my attorney fees
if you're bullying kids out there stop
it
damn facts facts all facts
never stops
oh my parent okay
[Music]
speaking i was talking about my parents
tick tock watch this [ __ ] they're such
they're so slick they really think
they're slick they're trying to promote
their cameo
watch this
hey babe what you working on
i'm doing a cameo
actually it's a girl who's turning 26 so
i'm just giving you some
advice and she wallace going berserk in
the background
my dad's shaking
26 but you know that i didn't know then
if i could tell myself anyway [ __ ]
anyway interesting you guys probably get
great i barely remember 26 so i hope you
were able to uh you know you don't get
mad and someone buzzes 26 seems like
yesterday so you're forgetful
i hesitated for a second yeah you guys
are doing me [ __ ] now dude
i just thought it was funny how they
were like plugging their
their cameo hey babe what are you doing
oh i'm just writing for my camera they
took a page from from zach remember that
was zach's promo he did the whole uh oh
i didn't hear you come in oh hi
[Laughter]
i'm honored
what is this gabe of celebrating his
return to the podcast
no it's just a meme he was just hammered
screaming uh drinking some champagne yo
i gotta ask gabe a question on friday
we discovered something pretty funny
about gabe nothing wrong with it but his
public likes oh
oh i have to he's our boy i gotta i
gotta ask what's up
or at least warn him that people can see
those right
his likes i mean listen i did the same
thing my own dad i love my dad
his public likes are wild bro
like straight up hard for p word
[Music]
i'm [ __ ] up i just drank all the
bottles that that period [ __ ]
[ __ ] me [ __ ] yeah
these guys need to slow down
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
go search his likes not to be in
yeah don't don't do that at work or
school no no no no no no
nope
yeah [ __ ] one of my favorite nights
wait love why does it matter i said
hardcore keyword what's wrong with the
word
is usually the other keyword oh
just some people
like normal p word not like create not
like criminal keywords like like dirty
content yeah i'm not as female genitalia
yeah
i could say way worse on this show yeah
no but i think he works no i think i'm
like
alluding to his like little kids yeah no
i i get it i was saying just
just say it
just [ __ ] say it
i want to say ass
i'm with you though love i thought that
at first as well oh my god no no no no
okay good i'm glad i clarified no gabe
is not like it's it's grown women it's
grown women
spit in my mouth look in my eyes
thank you for this is
disseminating through the chat right now
i'm seeing a lot of oh my god
yeah i mean go check it out it's pretty
wild it's shocking it's funny i mean it
was funny i got a kick look he's a he's
a grown man
you know
a man can look at whatever he wants
but it's hilarious coming from
titties games
yeah someone said gabe is team skeet he
might be
titties for sure someone wants us to
take calls okay let's see is somebody
saying that he just privated do you
think he's watching right now and was
like oh [ __ ] no they're still there
they're still there you got trolled bro
oh no there's a bunch of people are
saying his likes are private it's
probably they think it's on tick tock
but it's on twitter oh
maybe they might okay i see gabe's gonna
be like i loved you
we were a boy
okay wait yeah i was
yeah yeah not tick tock i think that
that was the confusion they're
definitely still there
i mean it's a lot of like
full on
a and p
holy [ __ ]
super perfect yeah very close up yeah
they don't like that kind of [ __ ] on
tick tock but twitter does not weather's
amazing
yeah he likes it really close up in
there you can smell it
hey um can someone grab me a saudi
what kind like a coke zero yeah
you got it baby thank you
thank you my boy
my brother take a call
okay what does this mean oh lost the so
this girl sophia says she lost virginia
the same way as zach on a cruise is was
it this oh no
oh no
she says it's a crazy story
um
how crazy could it be yeah you had sex
on a boat i mean thank you
oh god ian he's helping her shredder i
called shredder inc
how odd
[Laughter]
someone this mason says he sharted at
work and wants to share the story
that's it that made you good i don't
want to hear this yeah the sharding
story is like i'm also just wondering
like how how
deep can it be we have a fallback we
don't have to worry about that anymore
we can be less discerning with these
calls because if if if it's not going
anywhere else
mason who [ __ ] his pants at work
all right
mason
i understand you sharded that word
i did
unfortunately
did anyone notice
um actually it's funny because i do bond
service and i just kind of i do the push
and pray method
and uh
i guess whenever i pushed out
i thought like it was going fine and
halfway through it just like felt a
little liquid
but at first i didn't think it was
a shark because i it was raining outside
i live in florida so it's raining
and uh i pushed and prayed
and thank god no one was around but i
went over to the water hose and whenever
i went to wash my [ __ ] out
the [ __ ] water hose was clanked
and my co-worker i think he might have
saw me with my pants down
it sounds like you didn't pray hard
enough
what were you referring to it as the the
push and pray
method
yeah can you break that down for me a
little bit
it's like it's like your control to see
how can well you can control your
[ __ ]
uh-huh oh pretty much i thought i
thought that was like a mowing i think
jack hit it on the head
it's your shutter dude
okay so
i think anyone can tell you know you can
really tell if it's if it's going to be
a shard or not you're kind of 50 50 if
it's a dry one
so you [ __ ] your pants
you host yourself off that's the story
that's it yeah i just i just thought
that zach would appreciate that i think
that i think you found your target yeah
you found the target audience there all
right well you uh you know what
i always expect the godfather sound i
hear it and it never comes
maybe you're hearing [ __ ] man i don't
know
it's definitely there it's definitely
that i wish you would hear [ __ ] you
would have caught it yeah here
all right mason take care thanks for the
call and uh
what was it were you sick did you eat
something what did you figure it out
i eat a lot of gas station food i think
it was the taco bell the chicken wrap
bro you are the dangerously out there
that'll do that station food talk about
yeah i mean who knows at that point yeah
that'll do it do you just [ __ ] do you
[ __ ] your pants frequently
yeah uh i wouldn't say frequently you
have diarrhea a lot
um
you know what the guys are right you got
two exes i'm sorry mason i got it yeah
we gotta go we gotta go thank you buddy
thank you though and good luck
good luck with that satisfaction
okay that's what i'm saying so like
the story is he [ __ ] his pants
basically yeah it's not much of a story
um i did appreciate the push and pray
method you gotta man
yeah everyone said he said he was
in lawn services right no bond services
okay my my i was imagining he was a
gardener
and he was pushing and praying
he makes his own fertilizer i imagine a
mountain front yard it's like you got to
test the waters with it you know
you got to test it out
on the toilet
yeah that seems like a
better method but if you're in a
predicament where you can't you don't
have access to a bathroom and you think
you got to fart i mean you gotta test
the water i just yeah
okay
i almost started during the show a
couple weeks ago
well you're in good company i just why
does it yeah
everybody's [ __ ] on the show
has a lot of issues i gotta say
it's
it's interesting oh this sounds good
oh okay so this might tell me if what
you think because this could just be a
only fans plug but her story is
that her own cousin subscribed to her
only fans
i could see that i mean
i don't know her ethnicity but i could
see some nosy cousins doing some spying
you think it's no that seems like beyond
nosy
that's what do you guys think
interesting or no
potentially
what do you think dan
i'm sorry i wasn't paying attention
i was looking at the chat it's all good
not like we're doing a show here
part of the show is what monitoring the
chat what do you want from me what'd you
ask
i already explained it to 50 000 people
now i got to say it twice well you don't
i mean who cares what i her cousins
subscribe to our only fans
i don't even know who you're talking
about it's a caller oh okay
[Laughter]
why are you asking me what what what
what do i generally if you guys think
this is a good car there's three other
guys here what do you guys think that's
a good point you all need to speak up
pick the [ __ ] up
jesus all right i'm gonna take the call
you guys just be ready okay
okay here we go
hannah
hello
all right so
you are a i believe what they call a
spicy accountant
yeah
and i i promise i won't plug my only
fans if that's what you guys are worried
about well okay thank you i appreciate
that well sometimes people call and they
have alternative ulterior uh
ulterior
motives got it motive yeah
okay so are you are you pretty big on
only fans or are you like relatively
small
um i would say i'm smaller okay
and um
like how many how many uh mem i don't
know if there's members or followers or
whatever how many do you have there
um i think the highest i ever got was
like 150
so i would say i'm pretty small
okay
and like how far does this go what the
content you make there is it solo stuff
is it team stuff
i'm just curious
when we're people um i didn't love sweet
i do mostly solo stuff and occasionally
with my boyfriend
okay got it and so you found out that
your cousin
first cousin
um
yes yeah unfortunately and are you do
come from a family with lots of cousins
or small amount of cousins
um so
my family is from mississippi
and so i do
fall into that southern um stereotype
um the stereotype being that i have a
lot of cousins like the inbred
stereotype or the big family yeah i
guess so okay okay i'm
i'm like staunchly against that but
apparently my uh cousins are not
so how many cousins do you have
um
oh my god that's a great question um
i don't know well
my closest cousins my first cousins i
probably have like six it's really not
like that much i think
okay so
you have only like 150 or you have 150
followers so you you
what
dan what the [ __ ] i'm trying to open me
reeling the whole show oh my god what
the [ __ ] if you don't listen now what
are you playing uh
i'm bringing up something relevant for
the conversation mute your audio
auto play video it's an autoplay video
online you know what on a website i
apologize for dan
jesus every time it happens my heart
stops what was it by the way i'm trying
to look up uh what the most searched
porn category in mississippi is oh
that's interesting what is it because
some of them well i'm trying to look it
up but i had to close it real quick
because this [ __ ] website had an
autoplay video was that pornography or
literally yeah no it was i was opening
porn live on the show well if you're
going no i just opened a site that had
the article about it doing research and
they had
let's continue our conversation
so
uh how much is the how much is it to
subs follow you or whatever per month
oh did hannah
did she bounce
it got too chaotic for her maybe
what happened to hannah i was just
getting to the point yeah i don't know
no x's
smooth sailing yeah
you want to try to call back anna or
i'll i'm gonna have to drop you because
uh
well she's still on the line though huh
yes she's still in line
well i was curious if her cousins tried
to engage with her like that's her i was
i wanted to know if they had ever talked
about it yeah right do they know does
she do he know that she knows
wait they can hear her oh
well here uh i'm gonna
i'm gonna drop can you guys somehow
figure out how to get her back i don't
know what to do
yeah okay so olivia's gonna get her back
on the phone
yeah i was kind of curious
in the meantime
you guys want to rate
met gala outfits
let's do it
i thought it'd be fun oh we can do a
tier list oh that'll be fun
oh you guys put all these in a tier list
that's awesome
shout out to olivia great job olivia
okay so there's there's a lot of fits
here
you guys know that met gala it's a
fundraiser for um
the met right
i mean the met is an amazing museum in
new york one of the greatest you know in
the in the country for sure
um
and it's free actually so i get that
they i get the fundraising it's this
huge premier museum and all the all the
big museums in new york are free to the
public so very cool
i saw little nas bro
you need like a video to appreciate his
his was sick dude
he came in big ass cape
dawn some armor
it was on under the cape yeah he like
took off the robe to reveal yo that's
some straight final fantasy 14.
eden's garden savage armor bro
yeah i like little nos he's like he's
just all in on the [ __ ] i like it
and then this was under that
[ __ ] she must have been hot a
little
nas
thank you rudy here we've got the video
because i feel like this was the coolest
outfit definitely
nice pixels bro
nice pixels
yeah
dude come on
come on you should have had a sword i
feel like
true
i feel like he's big oversight like a
little r2d2 behind him
r2d2 he'll say c-3po
how dare you she just squat and took a
[ __ ] for zach and the red carpet
shout out to his family my dude oh
you're right because he looks like c-3po
sure from
yeah
i mean i guess so
didn't occur to me
uh but i hope he starts a trend let's
just start wearing [ __ ] medieval
armor to these events also
like he does like a pokemon evolved like
three times yeah steps i mean that's
pretty dope and then he does this final
uh
and it's a sexual dance
he does his final transformation
i love that how much work he did i mean
damn he he understood the assignment
you know
so that that's s tier obviously
unironic s2 yeah
a little nozzy
i mean okay i bro i'm just gonna say it
and i'm sorry if this offends you justin
bieber literally looks like a lesbian
somehow i just knew that's what was
going on i'm sorry but he just looks
like a [ __ ] he just he looks i'm
sorry i don't know how to say this but
he lit
what stop you guys are saying stop that
appears to be what they're saying maybe
i don't know what like he just does i
don't know what to say i mean i'm sorry
maybe i wasn't trying
that sound by itself
i mean is i mean can i not say that is
that offensive genuinely i don't know i
mean probably i don't know i mean i'm
not
exactly even zach is actually my ass
that's how you know
okay well regardless of
um
it's so s i want to say but i can't say
what i want to say
you didn't already say it
no there's no no
a lot of the chat is defining you saying
he looks like ellen
yeah i'd rather speak
i'm going to say
and this is a compliment to elliot page
he looks like elliot page
he does
he looks like
he looks like
you know i'm sorry i don't know what to
tell you i just see it yes
yeah elliot paige is a man
no elliot page is a man i know that okay
olivia's yelling at me now i know elliot
page is a man i know i know i know
that's what i mean
that's what i say is a compliment
compliment to elliot page i wasn't
trying i'm sorry
dad is dying
i know i know thank you olivia she's
yelling at me i know elliot page is a
man not a lesbian i know i'm just saying
they look like
i just thought his pants look really
goofy and
i'm just how are you guys
i just
saying what he looks like
i can't help it
in the roast of justin bieber on comedy
central for years ago i think every
comic that went on stage called him
lesbian but like no i think he's a
handsome i think he looks good i'm
jealous he's so he's like a skinny
legend he's super like
fit but in this picture particularly
maybe it's i don't know why it's like
he really it's like the ma
i don't want to say anything i don't
want to say anything
let's probably be rounding the uh
raiding the outfits i believe yeah their
outfits are are just you're at the mat
gala bro step it up i don't know she
looks fine but it's understated
i mean
i'm not impressed is one pant oh i guess
that's so [ __ ] big bro i was gonna
say is one bigger than the other but i
guess it's because he's holding it
up a little bit if you have to hold up
your pants then
i guess that's a book but
i i shouldn't say it i'm going to say
something i don't
even joe knows when to stop
honestly they're at the met gala his
pants are huge i'm bored
um i'm gonna give him a d i don't give a
[ __ ] yeah
i think that's appropriate
um
i'm gonna go d
okay
just i'm trying to be critical i'm
trying to be honest here
i mean there's not really anything to
say about this it's
not doing much for me
is it as bad as theirs no i'll give it a
c
i'm just trying not to get caught up
here nope you like it dan
it's a nice jacket but you know
it's also yeah i feel like you could buy
that from the gucci store off the rack
um
are you not supposed to do that at the
mecca or something i
i don't know i'm assuming that i don't
know jack [ __ ] well these are like
they're working with like designers to
make like this got it insane
who is this
oh i don't like her
i was like [ __ ] this is your
girl are you joking
that's your girl she she zach come on
now she
she tweet uh she cheated on edward i
don't like her i liked the twilight
movies yeah
she ruined them for me
did you really not know that was her
i didn't recognize her at first i was
like you can't be serious
i've repressed her for my memory
so let's see here this is pretty i mean
i like the dress is it denim
i doubt it but i can't
tell it's nice
i mean it's okay it's not
i'm not blowing you away i'm not a great
judge because a lot of times on this hot
really high fashion stuff they go this
is stunning i'm dying this is show
something i'm like it's okay
it's a bee for me
peace and love uh f tier easy so this is
this is like something right out of
[ __ ] h m like what the [ __ ] is this
that's pretty lame
oh what was the theme olivia
the theme so olivia's saying make also
interpret
the theme because nobody really fought
it the theme was america what is that
america what does that mean just
generally america that's like a lot
if that was the theme then the blue
jeans dress uh i think needs to go up a
tier
well
nothing more american than uh
denim i feel like anything could be
interpreted as america
[Music]
yeah like i remember
the first time we talked about this the
theme was like camp and everybody got
all like
everybody came in like crazy yeah
dresses and stuff and that was cool
america is way too general so i don't
blame people for not
following it
but regardless um
addison ray straight off the rack h m
it was specifically american fashion i
guess
in that case we have to i mean lil nos
x's suit of armor i don't think was very
american
looked like a emperor from
the middle ages
yeah but he still gets an ass i don't
give a [ __ ] that's still cool as hell
yeah
she's like i like red because of the
confederacy
we shall rise again
is addison a neoconfederate
i think she gets i don't know i think
she gets a d at least she tried harder
than these goons
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know
get to d
um
this is
dixie right
what is happening here
like what is happening so she's got a
big uh
she got a big hat with the
straw she's trying to be audrey hepburn
but she's an american soldier hiding
she's wearing a
it looks like she shed a little bit on
the floor here oh yeah she looks like is
uh
yeah
that's america
that's america
yeah you know
oh what is this
oh interesting looks like the fry kid
that's a vibe
it's a mega vibe mcdonald's listen i i
honestly i don't hate it i i know i know
if you guys are going to kill me for
saying that but i don't hate it
i mean i don't have an issue with what
she's wearing i i don't understand
what's going on on her head it's insane
like you got to keep that on the whole
can we see it from another angle please
like what if you got to go to the
bathroom like do you eat with it on no i
think these these people they
they have like a whole team that like
removes it for her
yeah it's a whole operation to go to the
bathroom in these outfits they usually
have two looks
there's like one outside and then they
change to something more somebody's
writing to me in all caps it was
american independence a lexicon of
fashion
okay
american independence it wasn't really
whatever the [ __ ] that change
so can we get it from another angle
please someone working on that
all right here you go dan here's a
little better look
damn she got that that looks worse it
looks like that bloodborne you got that
bloodborne though kind of
that's the fur from
from dark beasts it is worse it's way
worse she looks like a porcupine
uh fatberg suit somebody said yeah
totally
where is she
oh the fabric is easy god where is she
in down here
i've thought of that in a while is it
this
i can't tell where is she
that's not addison the one that you
brought out i put it back
i think
addison uh i mean dixie
oh [ __ ] oh i see here they are okay
so here's addison
dude there's way too many of these yeah
there's a [ __ ] lot dude
so wait there's too many of these
somehow
then i'm going to leave dixie in a c i'm
not going to hate on her too bad there
the hell i almost moved yeah i mean
i mean okay bro i get it but and by the
way i like the actor and everything but
i mean bro come on see this fits the
theme more though i know in the 70s
disco thing and stuff that's the
platform
dude
yeah i guess i don't know i maybe maybe
i'm being too hard on them i mean what
do you guys think i mean that one's
[Laughter]
okay so she's naked as usual
she looks good though it's a nice it's
interesting
i think it's nice i don't know can one
of the ladies support me if this is nice
or not olivia what do you think is this
nice olivia what did you think of
kendall's i mean i think it
yeah where's her pepsi
boring olivia said boring what the [ __ ]
boring
i mean it's not like it looks pretty
intricate
okay i don't know anything about fashion
our high fashion i feel like i
understand like streetwear but i don't
understand high fashion at all boring
too typical sam said it's blah
i don't give a [ __ ] it looks like her
last look for the met gala i
i used to watch uh
nothing different for kendall okay
boring
water
loser and ladies hater
i used to watch top uh
the chat seems to disagree i'm seeing a
lot of aes here i mean it's an amazing
dress i don't know
yeah i mean i'm seeing a lot of love for
it in the chat i feel like more dudes
would like it it's not even about her
like looking it's not about me being a
tractor i mean the dress is
very intricate
like it's really delicate mesh with
i mean i guess the diamonds are kind of
corny i don't know i don't understand
the [ __ ] i try i try so hard to
understand it yeah i used to watch top
uh top model or whatever no not top
model was uh
was one with tim gunn before they moved
to amazon
project runway with ela like we watch
every season together
and like i try so hard i understand i
like i want but i don't understand like
they'll pick the winner and i'll be like
why and everybody agrees that's the best
one and eal agrees and it's so obvious
everyone and i just i don't get it i
don't understand
get the [ __ ] out of here
that's my review of this
get the [ __ ] out of here
wait he's wearing chucks it's like a
tony montana with chucks
i kind of like it
i don't
i don't like it
the fact that anyone chucks with it is
kind of epic
you hate it though
i don't know something about the baggy
pants
and then the really tight top and the
baggy pants maggie pants are coming back
i don't know about this one again why is
his top got to be so tight and then his
pants so baggy it's just i don't know
it's the mc hammer look
it is
it's coming back
um
it's i feel like it's so much harder for
guys to stand out um cool i guess i
don't know that's american
dude in a dress i mean it's fine nothing
super crazy but he looks good i guess
this [ __ ] let's go
it's the globe dude's kissing the whole
globe i mean it looks like he's having
fun i can't say that i
that one's interesting at least i don't
know if i like it but that's as good as
i don't know if i like it but i
appreciate
whatever this is that's
like the message not the look
i mean obviously it's not a street look
it could be
uh what's his name
the problem is the problem is it looks
like a kind of like a home project like
it's just a collared shirt with like
half of the end of a bed sheet sewn onto
you know like the construction seems
really bad
but anyway i like the outside of little
little nosses this is the first one that
at least
yeah it's really eyebrow razor i agree i
saw billy eilish i thought she looked
great
loved the dress
yes
love it
do people agree with that
i mean people okay generally literally
like hers i i i'm like you i don't know
how to olivia and sam am i uh in the
majority opinion and thinking that she
looks good
i just want to know where i'm at here
because we're like oh everyone hated it
and i'll be like what
she looks beautiful says olivia okay
thank you finally i'm right or at least
i understand
i mean the color
complements her look the flow he's very
uh well made classic too like uh
turn of the 20th century very elevated
okay we love it
whoopsie daisy marilyn monroe etc says
uh
olivia very american right yeah i agree
whoopsie daisy out here whoopsie daisy
looking like a damn
try not to get cancelled
i don't like it though it's just i think
it's horrible
um
i i don't know what to make of that it
looks like it's made the material looks
odd like she looks she looks like she's
in a [ __ ] overs
what i can say it just looks like it
looks like a tarp
i was gonna say she looks like she's in
a
in a trash bag right i wouldn't i mean
that's what the material looks like
it looks like her she's she's shown up
for her quinceanera or whatever
[Music]
i don't know if i pronounced it right
she also looks like a pinata
[Laughter]
this is a bad look
it's very weird
it is eye-catching though h3 colors
right she's rocking the the purple and
teal
she's dressed as a slip and slide
not good
she looks like the back of a girl's head
when they're getting their hair colored
chance
this dude is so goofy i'm sorry i liked
him but um i'm i'm over it and i have no
comment
i don't know what up though i don't
really care either
grimes is a i'm so over grimes and
kneeling like dude nobody cares
nobody cares
you know what i i despise them um i
think that this is pretty cool i can't
lie
she recently said her kid doesn't call
her mom i find that so desperate their
whole
thing i feel like it's so sad but um
[ __ ] up when your own but i do think
that that outfit is pretty cool looking
maybe because she looks like a dark
souls character yeah exactly
she looks like a boss yeah she looks
like a boss from dartmouth
to care about her
there's a story with her sword it was
like melted down from guns or something
whatever don't care
very polarizing on hers in the chat i'm
seeing only fs and s's for grimes
i don't know i just i i have no opinion
i mean this is nice but it's a little
too like a
show girl or whatever but that's very i
feel like that's on theme
yeah that's true it looks really i think
it's pretty cool yeah that's pretty
crazy yeah
still don't know how you go to the
bathroom
i think am i right you just make a [ __ ]
on the floor zach
is it like a you got a circle you push
your face
i think you need to plan your bathroom
breaks accordingly at an event like this
do you just like hold it the whole night
or like like what do you do
i would assume that they probably go to
the bathroom during the outfit switch
or they're all wearing diapers
i think that'd be the move man
you gotta look good over you know
going to the bathroom i'm still seeing
really funny comments and read them chat
about grimes
well it's
somebody said that she's on that dancer
the boreal valley type beat
it's one of the dark souls
yeah i remember dancer the boreal
it's pretty accurate actually dancer of
the bathroom god i'm waiting for the
chat to catch up it's going crazy
oh yeah it does that weird thing where
it like falls when i switch off it
doesn't it yeah it like buffers all the
messages
that's pretty annoying
um so i don't know i mean it's cool i
guess
oh speak oh is that justin bieber
i didn't even realize he was at the same
event
[Music]
there is a similarity you have to admit
maybe i wasn't trying
this outfit's pretty basic which
probably just go with the next yeah i
agree it's basic nice boots though sick
actually let me see them but they're
sick some bad ass boots
[Music]
um
what in the [ __ ]
it's okay it's crazy it's cool it's
weird
you boy
little diamond forehead or what's his
name
wait
didn't i hear that somebody stole his
diamond yeah is it not in his head
anymore i can't really tell from out of
his forehead he got it back he got it
back somebody yanked yeah he got it back
you know when we when we first talked
about the story you're you put me up to
the task ethan the ghost deal is oh yeah
i remember people were clipping that
right and saying they know who took the
diamond yeah someone thanosed his ass
yeah
i'm not sure what is going on here he's
got like a bagpipe that's mother gonna
play
exo life tour on the bagpipes
as he gets around man i see him in a
palestinian wedding on tick tock i saw
that yeah i mean actually i don't hate
his outfit to be honest it's kind of i
don't know but i i don't know what the
[ __ ] do i know
i saw his i didn't like it i immediately
i don't know why i didn't like it i just
i'm tired of pete davidson he's serving
savage looks savage i'm sorry i know
there's a lot of pete davidson fans and
people like him i just i'm tired of
seeing him
and i'm tired of [ __ ] machine gun
kelly too the two of them can go through
oh he's way worse than pete davidson
he's way worse i like pete
pete's occasionally funny and i didn't
see his movie but apparently he he's got
some acting chops he was in a movie
recently oh yeah and like a dramatic
role and people thought he did really
well king of staten island he's really
good i never really found him all that
funny on snl but um
but sometimes sometimes he can be
i don't like the outfit
what are you what do the ladies think
because i feel like they have a better
end ladies ladies should they just come
down here
um they can just tell me on discord
she's uh sam's typing sam's got a lot to
say on this one i'm sure yeah i'm really
curious what the ladies think about this
outfit ladies i love pete davidson says
olivia to be honest love the l they love
it olivia says biggest celeb crush it's
so [ __ ] up i can't escape this guy
like the ladies are obsessed with this
guy he's a hottie what can you do
okay fine just leave me alone god i'm
tired of hearing about him
let me check out his hairline pretty
good hairline not bad
not mine
i always see writer poses say i look
like him so i like him but just because
you look like him does it look like him
no i don't think i like the twilight
movies oh i do zack
everybody loves him
everybody loves pete davidson
frank ocean always crushing it with
shrek baby straight from the swamp
that's [ __ ] hilarious
i don't know what the [ __ ] this is but
i'm dig it that's s t man yeah that does
here
uh who's this lord yeah good lord
good lord
she got that mid samara look going on i
don't get it and i don't care
virgil
um
what is up with virgil
uh once again i don't care i don't get
it those glasses are kind of hyped
though what are they gonna say
what does it say modernity on the front
sam said that pete davidson has what the
internet calls butthole eyes the ladies
love it
what the [ __ ] does that happen they're
like sunken no it's he has a disease
that's why um
yeah come on sam corona
yeah you guys find crohn's sexy that's
when you like can't stop [ __ ]
well that's not exactly what it is but
well it's like i know i i i'm being
no wait so you get sexy eyes from crones
it makes your it makes you have dark
circles around your eyes
you look like damaged and a bad boy
you're like hey i don't i don't sleep
and i don't want [ __ ] butthole sexy
eyes it's an awful disturbing mr beast
has crohn's
says
actually i know that about him man
okay virgil i don't know what the [ __ ]
you're doing burning in their butthole
cam you want to throw that up down
yeah
um who's this
that's james charles wait literally do
you know this
oh it is oh okay
this is oh so cameron's wondering if i
like it now that they're put in
the final fantasy 14 and you know what's
funny they actually fit in there pretty
yeah no bad pretty effortlessly
virgil is cracking me up the most
yeah now i like it you're right
good call game sometimes you just have
to recontextualize this got a lot of
heat the tax the rich
um
aoc's tax the rich got a lot of
lot of heat
i think what was your take on that dan
my take is that i'm annoyed that i had
to even think about it or have a take on
it so obviously afc huge socialists
and conservative media lost their mind
being like oh tax the rich but you're
hobnobbing with the rich honestly not
just conservative media
a lot of leftists found it pretty
distasteful as well
honestly i just um
i don't i just don't care
i i don't know i really just don't care
either way it's like if you're wondering
what my uninformed opinion is is that i
don't think there's anything wrong with
it
even the optics of it
are not that bad
she is a representative from new york
she got invited to the event
right and so she was probably like how
do i go to this event but also because
if she went there and didn't do tax the
rich she would get [ __ ]
right i
imagine and that would be worse don't go
would be just don't go
i don't know enough about like they're
celebrities they're not like [ __ ] uh
they're not like the people crushing
middle america they're just celebrities
i think those people probably do go too
to be honest you think they crush
there's some crushing going on virgil
crushes
i mean i know he's a huge
i don't know my algorithm i mean so this
this whole event is a is a fundraiser
for a museum
right
a free museum it's the arts i mean it's
just i mean she's from new york like i
you know i guess she can go but it's
just a museum yeah
i do find like putting the message on
the dress a little cringe but i also
just don't
i just don't care
yeah it's like really scary there just i
think it's ugly by the way
like the t i guess doesn't look that
good yeah
it just is not
a big enough deal to deserve
weeks of discourse yeah it was insane
you know what i mean about it
but ultimately it didn't really bother
me i get what she was doing and
yeah i mean her argument was she's just
trying to bring that message to a place
where like all the rich people are um
which it's
i guess
i mean people did talk about it
right true
i mean if that was the goal
very soon you go to hell i don't know
who this is
are we sure they all say the names under
the but i like his fl his theodore would
like his outfit so i like it
i'm saying that the met gala isn't i'm
sorry the museum isn't free yes it is i
used to live in new york i've been there
a million times all public museums in
new york are free you you don't have to
pay they have a booth there but you can
walk in they can't charge you
oh like it's donations only yeah well
there you go it's free
google it
google it yeah i'm
if this is the right website 25 for
adults 17 seniors
free for a caregiver and accompanying
visitor
that's all i'm saying about free it's
free
is the mat
well we're talking about the
metropolitan
museum
right
i believe so it's free for new york
residents says cam it says maybe the
following and general admission tickets
but you may pay what you wish
well there you go got it and i wish to
pay nothing yeah
like panera pears
i don't know if you guys have those out
here
what paneer what did you say
panera carrots you guys have those
you could pay based on a donation at
panera this is cool i know all right
this is beautiful like her dress
okay now i have a strong opinion that i
like a dress can you can sam
and
olivia going to tell you
dead
yeah back me up here
and the verdict from the ladies
olivia says i don't love it
but i don't understand she said it's
pretty but i don't love it what i don't
get it what is with this i don't
understand the logic
sam what do you think sam
lay it on us
here we go
and nah dog she said nah dog
what the different tastes people have
beautiful what the [ __ ] the problem
with this
it's a no from me
bro what the [ __ ] what is chat then what
do i don't understand fashion i don't
understand high fashion at all somebody
says it looks like shaving cream i do
kind of see that okay well
i mean that doesn't mean it's bad
no
because it resembles shaving cream
uh
kid cuddy out here looking like the
joker
you got butthole eyes
i'm not into it
it icon
are you just saying that because you're
a fan or you actually like the outfit i
like it
okay what the [ __ ]
is he wearing a
g-shock isn't he
that's [ __ ]
i like the color that's a throwback it's
the matching the the eye makeup i love
all of it sorry what matches in this
like his hair with the pants and the oh
fair enough
ladies what do you think
you know what i i can't i'm frustrated i
don't get it what the [ __ ] is this you
guys probably love this [ __ ] too huh
okay i think this is the dark penguin
that's the bloodborne yeah that's
bloodborne sorry
for sure this is the penguin y'all
probably love this one too
olivia likes the kid cudi
of course she does
you can just take the opposite of
whatever i like
so does sam
love it good [ __ ]
the dude has a damn shower curtain on
his pants
okay kim k kim is obviously the worst
right like damn someone said what what's
the deal you gotta pay like a dlc to
unlock her outfit or what
i mean it's pretty dramatic i guess i
think it's iconic it got the most buzz
yeah it it is it looks very [ __ ]
stupid it's very dumb it's a [ __ ]
idiot if it wasn't kim you guys wouldn't
say that i [ __ ] hate her it's good
good outfit it is a great outfit
i i think it's fine actually i i don't
i'm not gonna hate on it
this one got a lot of buzz too peg the
patriarchy i saw like ben shapiro and
all the likes being like but penguin's a
sexual act you know
i can't believe she's going to the red
carpet and talk about sexual acts it's
just so inappropriate extra large and
extra hard
which i guess she pegged the
people she wanted to but the outfit is
pretty bad i mean what is it
what do i know i'm dunking my opinion
i'm wrong about everything
what'd you guys think about the peg the
patriarchy somebody give somebody like
the other one it's just it's a little
irony for me the peg
i mean it is a little 14 and this is
deep yeah
patriarchy bro
all right ladies what do you think about
the pet i don't like
bad knock okay finally thank you we all
agree
i don't know what the [ __ ] cool dude i
mean i don't care
[Laughter]
why this
okay he's wrapped in a blanket
cool i think it's fine do we like it is
it asap and rihanna
yeah it's cruella de vil and her son who
just woke up from a nap
i mean what the [ __ ]
the blankets though i'd like to have
that blanket
uh is that j.lo
it says under all of these if you wanted
to check there you go don't care
love her i think she's a fan of the show
i think
really yeah
where'd you hear that
her and ela got in contact or something
what on instagram i don't know
who is it that is uh olivia rodrigo oh
no slant no olivia slander in this show
i don't know anything that's here to
tell you the truth
but that's cool bro i [ __ ] thought
sean mendes looks so dumb
i [ __ ] hate his look and don't any of
you girls dare disagree with me
you guys tell me now sam and olivia
you've i dare you to [ __ ] tell me you
like his luck i dare you sam says corny
thank you finally we agree
go ahead olivia
little cheesy
okay sam says she hate it tell us what
you think though olivia
don't say a little cheesy you you tell
me what about this outfit
why does he have two belts
and a suspender suspenders with belts
[ __ ] got two belts and
suspenders
he just looks like the douche at a
halloween party
it's giving share somebody said
yeah that was a big controversy he said
uh of his girlfriend's outfit that it's
giving him share vibes and everyone
accused him of being gay for saying that
right am i getting that right i don't
know
um
cool nice i guess
pretty much
same vibe as the uh no opinion gender
one everyone's going crazy over emma's
outfit
i mean i guess because it's made of
jewels and stuff i mean i like emma i
think she looks good and i'm a fan but i
don't understand all the hubbub about
her dress i mean just because it's like
beautifully made
can someone explain the hubbub
look as a [ __ ]
yeah i don't i didn't really hear any
hubbub really
everyone's talking about it
um
bruh
you good
[Laughter]
that's a nice dress i think but what do
i know someone will tell me i'm an idiot
all right i'm out yeah let's uh
let's take care of our other um
ads my dude we got two more to go
man's about to put imagine oh yeah
cam made a good point shawn mendes about
to
do some magic in vegas
my freak
my friend dude i miss chris angel i used
to watch his show all the time he seems
like your type of guy is
as fake as it was i used to love your
show
it got me into magic oh somebody would
you consider yourself a mind freak [ __ ]
yeah dude joker brain freaking
about to say i don't we might have been
off on the whole joker brain thing
olivia
wanted me to add this one apparently
people want to talk it's a native
american activist she looks
great right
we love it or does she look bad
yeah i think it looks great it looks
great yeah
i love the turquoise and gold
i can't
i don't have the wrong opinion on this
dress
you can have an opinion
no i thought i looked great we love a we
love a native american queen
sorry about everything i wasn't here my
family was not here
huh i said sorry about everything to her
what are you
ever the native american activist oh
you're trying to say
your family is not responsible for the
genocide of the native americans no okay
but do i benefit from the
system i get yeah probably
that's critical race theory dan
congratulations jake campbell
all right a few more sponsors two more
real fast guys thank you thank you ryan
cavanaugh eat your heart out
policy genius summer's coming to an end
and the leaves are about to fall but
mother nature does her thing to prepare
for the
new season excuse me it's that uh coke
zero
you can do yours by getting free life
insurance quotes with policy genius
policy genius makes it easy to compare
quotes from over a dozen top insurers
all in one place why compare because you
could be saving fifty percent or more on
life insurance by beca by comparing
quotes with policy gives genius and even
better you could save thirteen hundred
or more per year on life insurance by
using policy genius to compare policies
the license experts at policy genius
work for you not the insurance company
so you can trust them to help you
navigate
every step of the shopping and buying
process that kind of service has earned
policy genius five-star reviews
thousands of them across trust pilot and
google and eligible applicants can get
covered in as little as a week
thanks to an award-winning policy option
that swaps the standard medical exam
requirements for a simple phone call
that's nice this exclusive policy was
recently rated number one
by forbes advisor higher than the
options from ladder ethos and bestows
[ __ ] cowards
the competitors aren't [ __ ]
[Music]
it's all about policy genius
all you got to do to get started is go
to policygenius.com
h3tv and in minutes you can work out how
much life insurance coverage you need
and compare personalized quotes to find
the best price when you're ready to
apply the policy genius team will handle
the paperwork and scheduling for free
policy genius doesn't add on extra fees
head to policy policygenius.com
h3tv to get started right now policy
genius when it comes to insurance it's
nice to get it right
unlike those other [ __ ] easy
got him
raycon
i actually love raycons
the value you get for these suckers
is
unbeatable
uh yeah a tiny little sucker they're
basically
high-end air pods
uh for half the cost
uh whether you you know i listen to them
all the time i mean what do you need
when you're walking working out you're
eating or whatever when you're doing the
show sometimes
yeah right now i'm not saying music
right now yeah i don't even pay
attention to this [ __ ] whether you use
them to pump up wind down work out or
work
just straight up work raycons are my
go-to for the audio
and the new everyday buds look feel and
sound better than ever with an improved
rubber oil look and feel
how does it feel give it a couple of
feel there damn
and optimize gel tips for the perfect
in-ear fit these are impressive before
you even start listening go ahead give
it a feel
feels nice
damn
um
you get three new sound profiles to make
sure everything you're listening to
sounds its best with just the right
amount of bass pure mode this is for
listening to podcasts blues
instrumentals they've got a balanced
mode for uh
podcasts uh rock heavy metal and bass
mode that's for hip hop edm reggae you
know what it is there's also an all new
awareness mode for when you need to
listen to your surrounding
sure your surroundings that's great you
know
raycon offers eight hours of play time
with a 32 hour battery life there's also
built-in mic so you can take calls on
your earbuds at the press of a button
raycon start at half
the price of other premium audio brands
but they sound just as good and raycon
comes with a 45-day happiness guarantee
that's a risk-free buy
right now people
listeners can get 15 percent off their
raikon orders
at
buyracon.com h3 that's buy raycon
dot com slash h3 to fit save fifteen
percent off
on raycon by raycon
dot com slash h3 thank you thank you
peace and love we love you
ryan cavanaugh right now i'll be like
crying a little baby little baby cry
baby i'm never [ __ ] cry baby
i wanted to bankrupt them hey guess what
five sponsors you say
um let me get a piece of that action
dude that's a really good photoshop well
done change the skin color
no i think he just replaced the whole
photo but oh it's just a whole new thing
yeah
nice yeah this isn't white face
oh no
right
i would never accuse him of that
um
real quick just because uh
there's a bunch and they've been
stacking up just some super chats go
ahead somebody donated a hundred bucks
just to say shredder is a dope dog name
oh thank you so much
thank you for the handy thank you for
the hundy for that thank you thank you
isaac said uh
i got to give this to my boy love i feel
like
he i get in the much love he he deserves
love his
face and his picks he puts
love shout out that's 50 bucks
what do you think about that love
the 50 bucks yeah that's a lot of
thinking it's interesting love is
actually the one that collects the
messages for me to read off and
it's very meta interesting that he
selected that one it's it's all in good
feed man yeah it's all good michael said
uh i want to call in about a lawsuit my
fiance and i are on need advice on our
attorney as well
um i like advising on that i mean
obviously i'm not illegal but i feel
like i have a really good handle on that
stuff how much you charge for that
400 an hour i don't know some attorneys
are up to like 800 so 750. yeah undercut
them a little bit that's good
uh gingerbed420 asks love is there
cowboys in switzerland
yeah this one i added on purpose because
people think i live in switzerland man i
think he lives yes switzerland is a
different country than sweden in case
that was unclear to some people
yep
all right
[Laughter]
also um the girl who we lost on the call
earlier uh she is in the queue um hannah
okay good let's
we want to pick it up yeah all right
hannah let's try again um bringing her
in right now
hello hannah
hello anna you back
i am back can you hear me we can hear
you just fine
awesome okay so so why was this i don't
know what happened okay well i'm glad to
have you back this is important
so we were just getting to the point
where you have 150
followers how much does it cost to
become a follower
um so
i because only fans did its thing
where they were gonna ban it and then
they backtracked um
i dropped it i think to ten dollars
and then i started over at fansly and
that's like three subscriptions here
wait so what's the cost monthly now
right now
um for only bands it's ten dollars okay
ten bucks and how long has your cousin
been following you
oh my gosh i
probably like
a year before i found out
oh wow okay and he's okay so okay this
is interesting
and um
wow so how did you feel when you saw
that he was following you were you
embarrassed were you surprised
um
i don't know i guess it was really
triggering
like really uncomfortable
um
i think it's the best way to put it like
yeah just really gross
and is this a closing uh a cousin you've
been close to or is he kind of distanced
thank you
um i grew up with him so he actually
like babysit me and stuff like he's
older than me
oh no
oh
that just took a time for the word now
i'm gonna ask you kind of she's the most
important question
so when you found out did you say
something to him
have you guys ever talked about it
we haven't talked about it i think i i'm
i'm too scared to bring it up
and are you 100 you're 100 sure it's him
yeah so like um sometimes i'm nosy when
people like sub to my only fans i like
look at their
um like profile pictures and it was a
picture of him so he didn't have his
like official name which is why i didn't
catch him immediately
but i was like looking at people's like
profile pictures and that was his face i
was like oh my god do you think he so is
he still following
you no no i blocked him and then i i p
blocked him
oh so you in a weird way got him to stop
following you
oh yeah yeah and then i like deleted my
twitter and i started a new twitter
just kind of started right from like the
ground up
do you do you suspect that he knows that
you know
do you think he
um
he has to
there's no way
i mean he would know if he was
subscribed and suddenly he's he's
blocked right well she blocked and
unlocked like on twitter oh like the
software block and unblock and it forces
them to stop following right yeah
i'm assuming that's why i deleted my
whole twitter
yeah but you went to great lengths to
basically shake him
so he must he probably well dude but my
other question is like do you think he
wanted you to know that he was following
you that's like the because he had his
photo he didn't even try and hide it
yeah
yeah exactly like he changed his name
but he didn't
he might just be stupid to be honest but
but yeah he he kept his profile picture
of him so like a part of me is like is
this like a weird he's trying to send
you a message
yeah is he married or anything like that
um
i think he's been
married twice or something but i don't
think he's in a relationship now i don't
live in the same state as him so i don't
have any opportunities to run into him
thankfully
man so do you guys ever have like family
outings where you're forced to see him
family gatherings no
no no
his whole side of the family is pretty
much like
excommunicated because they're really
weird
you don't can't imagine why
oh
did you tell any of your family
um i told my mom my mom knows what i do
for work and she's very supportive
zapped you how do you feel about that
um
that's cool i guess
i'm sorry you sound very sweet i just
have add but
you sound like very sweet you know you
do i'm autistic too
wait
just like a b do you say you're autistic
ab
i say i have a dd
and she was just saying as well not that
like like her yo you gotta fix that
sound bites that i feel like i'm going
into the godfather bit every time yeah i
did some who did the second zap i didn't
see it was not me
i think i got but anyway that's i'm
thank you for sharing i actually do i
did think it was interesting so
thank you uh what was your name again
my name's hannah or cersei
oh she dropped it
no no
are you not the full
thank you good luck with your um
good luck with your endeavor there and i
wish y'all the best thanks for calling
yeah thanks for listening have a good
day guys bye see
ya bye
yeah i guess it's it's helpful that
they don't interact much but do you i
would i would guess in a way he's trying
to be like
oh did i
i think you just shut down the whole
thing
why do i even have that power take that
away from me well i can't i mean you
you're the host you're the host
it's right um we should probably uh
think about wrapping it up soon really
how long we've been going well i'm we've
been going a while and i've also uh
you've got some things to do i do yes
i've gotten a message from you from your
wife
asking the [ __ ] do you want to wrap it
up
here for it to me some business stuff
it's in our chat
let me check my calendar maybe there's
something on here
you've got some tv
we have been going for about two hours i
don't see anything on my calendar and
plenty more to talk about this guy's
tripping well i mean
shannon can you find out from elo what
is
that
i don't see anything on calendar i don't
see oh it's something in whatsapp yeah
yep
uh
oh
she's not there's no there's not that
much pressure she's saying she wanted to
meet
yeah
she was asking if we were gonna be done
soon
it's a lot more content yeah okay people
haven't said i'm just letting you know
you hadn't i know you hadn't seen that
so
you know
you know dude i want a [ __ ] about final
fantasy 14. i've been playing this game
a lot and i know some of you guys don't
care but i find the end game is really
unfair like i grinded and grinded i got
to level 80 and then i grinded all my
end gear game to be like raid ready and
these fights at the end of the game are
so like the difficulty curve goes from
easiest game you've ever played to so
[ __ ] brutally hard it's like getting
your balls stuck it's so [ __ ] hard
and then you're in a group of like 12
people if one person [ __ ] up the whole
raid wipes that's how it goes and you
know it's like how do you even learn
these fights and people get all salty
because they're like
no noobs and so well how am i supposed
to learn you can't it's a it's just a
mess i just feel like uh i feel like a
second class citizen in that game right
now
it's just not fun
got you
that's it that's all i have to say
thank you
the devious licks you guys want to talk
about the keemstar memes or the tv i
mean i never it's all good i can't talk
about keemstar
too little keemstar uh has been tweeting
all month
about talking to young fans and being
disgusted by women his own age and it
was used in a book huh
instead of book keemstar said woman my
own age try that
woman my old age
so he's been dming fans
and uh kim oh so this tweet went like
mega viral on the cringe subreddits and
stuff
uh this is what i was referring to
he says you guys keep telling me to date
someone my own age well i googled 39
year old woman
i will not be listening to you guys i
will not be listened to you guys right i
give them too much credit if you
remember where you were on 9 11 i'm not
interested
there's such an insane statement bro
i don't know if you've looked at
yourself
and then you know
yeah so this so i think this woman was
actually a missing
she's missing and her body was found
like she was i believe
i think multiple of these yeah
so he grabbed women who are missing
and potential homicides
and use them to trash their appearances
that's a news guy by the way
that's a news man
checks his sources
huh
yeah both these
uh they're missing
they're missing people
hilarious
uh not
missing 39 year old woman and kim's like
look at her who would want it dude what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you bro
this one popped off yeah i wonder why
someone said i think you should just
fall off the planet
damn i seen one of your streams and
thought what kind young lady i'm highly
disappointed in this aggression towards
me and i will no longer be having such a
favorable opinion about you and she said
we all know you were just checking my
profile to see if i'm under 21.
busted bro
yeah but this tweet was actually shared
widely
by a lot of the cringe channels
and it is quite a legendary tweet i have
to say i think he erased it
uh and shame
you know what else what's next he should
erase and shame youtube
uh one of the girls he posted was
actually found
dead so
that's actually just not funny at all
and just super [ __ ] up that he's bla i
mean imagine blasting out a missing
person who's found that
for being ugly that's keemstar i'm
busted that's [ __ ] under who does
that
who
literally who would do that
it's so frustrating so [ __ ] up
damn
side meme
top of the morning top of the morning
top of the morning let's get it
top of the morning and top of the
morning and you won't and you want to
know why keemstar hates me
it all comes down to that look at me
and look at him
look at me
and look at him
okay uh typewriter sound please
[Applause]
dear
susan waginski
typewriter please
today ethan made fun of my hairline
and i can't lie
it really
got to me
hi oh yeah uh video please keep up the
video
[Music]
uh we have a special video to accompany
the letter here there it is
dear susan wojcinski
today ethan made fun of my hairline
and it wouldn't bother me so much if his
hairline wasn't absolutely [ __ ]
perfect
i dream about ethan's hairline i love
defense airline and it makes me so mad
you don't think i've tried to pick up
women my own age
they would never
date me in a million years
i have to pick up young impressionable
girls who don't know any better and have
no life experience
and even those relationships only last
two weeks when they realize what a
creepy time
anyway susan i just wanted to send this
clip to you
to say you need to ban ethan klein right
now
you need to get this video removed from
the internet
i'm going to write my rep from youtube
20 emails
with pictures of ethan's hairline this
is not fair
ethan should be banned just for how bomb
his hairline is
do you know how hard life is okay i
should make fun of the airline
anyway susan
in short
i love you
i do anything for you
[Music]
and you know
don't think ill of me because i date 20
year olds
somebody's got to take care of them
i have a corvette and they love it so
cool my corvette
and we go on
atvs
and i have an arcade game we play arcade
games
and we order cheese pizza i don't like
toppings i guess i just not i guess i
never got there long email i don't know
susan's a busy woman i don't know if
he's gonna be able to read all this
i guess some things never change
oh okay thank you the signed keemstar
ben ethan thank you
some there's a call people want us to
take
found out her uncle was her dad via
ancestry bro no [ __ ] way yeah so i
because you hung up i had to
do a little wizardry to get back into
the system hopefully it worked let's
click call and see what happens and
we'll see what happens vanessa are you
there
hello hello yes i'm here it worked okay
i'm very interested so
vanessa you
found out your
dad's brother
is actually your real dad
no
so what happened is
is um my aunt and my uncle of course
were married which my aunt is my mom's
sister
and um so my mom never told me like my
whole life who my dad was even though
like my sisters i have other sisters one
who passed at a very young age but they
all had different dads and they knew who
their dads were but i never knew who my
dad was and so i always ask her and like
cry and stuff and ask like well i just
want to know who my dad is you know and
she would never tell me and um
they ended up divorcing and then got
well they have a weird relationship now
it's just weird but my aunt when i found
out everybody like freaked out of course
i did too and i was like what the heck
like this is so weird and so somebody
reached out to me in the like ancestry
has like a dm
and they reached out to me and they were
like hey
you know um who's your mom and all this
kind of stuff and i thought it was a
troll
and so i started telling them like well
who's your mom and all that and then i
realized like her relatives were my
uncle's relatives
and like i've known them my whole life
so i was just like that's really weird
and it was like so your dad is my uncle
and i was like
what
how is that even possible so
i called up my mom and i was like hey
did you ever sleep with uncle so and so
i don't want to say his name and um
she was like uh why
and i was like well
my ancestry is saying that like i'm
related to his family
and so is he my dad and she was like
yeah
i never wanted to tell you but
you know
he is and i was like
crazy
so wait let me get this straight your
mom is related to your biological dad
how
no my mom and my aunt are related and my
uncle
is married to my aunt oh so she so
you're your mom [ __ ] mary your mom
[ __ ] her sister's husband her sister
oh [ __ ] yeah
so so live together
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa we got we got
x's on dude
you got two x's
okay well that's fine yeah brutal well i
was interested well that's a hell of a
story i hope your family's doing okay
aftermath of that is everything okay no
well
a little
a little bit so my sister cousins and my
cuz bro like they accept me and so does
like my aunt she's like told me to call
her mom and stuff which is weird because
i was like i've known you my whole life
as my aunt all right and i call my dad
get those 2x's uh
uh yeah they're playing the they're
playing the toilet sound i'm so sorry
okay
all right have a good day
thank you so much thank you for sharing
okay
okay
brutal you guys did the toilet sound on
her
now what happened because i saw somebody
reach over to dan's buzzer
now what was that exactly i don't know
what you're talking about
dan why did you buzz why did you bother
dude
somebody reached over to dance buzzer i
buzzed her but dan i mean that's dan
that's what i missed savage moments and
went to the bathroom come on now the
caller so apparently
her mom
[ __ ] her sister's husband
her mom [ __ ] her sister's husband
that's her dad oh brutal
yeah that's unfortunate it is um you
press the button you should let her if i
did not pressure you to let her finish
dan all right well i guess we should
wrap it up at this point
there's so much there's so much left but
we'll save it we got we got three more
shows this week good to be back thank
you everyone for tuning in
so
just get the schedule straight
we're back on
thursday really that long
we're recording off the rails on
wednesday yeah
it'll be up on thursday it'll be up on
wednesday it's like a bonanza it's
thursday friday sunday
right end of the week
i saw some people saying that you're
like kanye with uh dondo with all of the
delays on the new show yeah it might be
it's just i don't know you guys i'm
sorry i'm trying theoretically it'll be
uh this weekend
it is a real thing that we're working on
it's
right it actually does exist it's ready
it's just
things keep happening you know
love y'all somebody uh donated 20 bucks
that ethan hit me up for final fantasy
14 game session i can carry you through
the savage content how can you carry me
nobody can carry me it's like if one
person is in the wrong spot the whole
group wipes it's [ __ ] outrageous it's
so
punny it's like so hard and the game was
so easy before that have you
have you um i don't know if you tried
this but have you considered getting
good
thanks yeah wow nice one
nice one dude yes i have tried that
actually i tried it dude tonight i
wrapped this we should try harder dude
that is your boss
freaking savage moment compilation put
that in the savage moment compilation
you guys ready for all the reddit posts
about the buzzers
why do you think people are mad about
them oh yeah people are mad
they seem to not get the point
[ __ ] it you sound defensive who cares
people are mad geez uh no i'm i'm fully
ready to be there
wait are you are you freight here let's
go to the subreddit are people mad about
the business for you
wait
are you sure
i don't give a [ __ ]
i like the twilight movies
i just care about twilight
i don't think people be mad about it i
hope this doesn't make you sound like a
douche
dude you say that with such gusts though
no people are gonna be mad
i don't know
oh here's a post from eight hours ago
wow
the inconsistency sucks and i'm getting
over it what do you want i took a week
off
says the show really depends on how
ethan is feeling that day what do you
mean
oh they're saying they're inconsistency
of the show this post is let's be honest
the show really depends on how ethan is
feeling that day and is taking a toll on
the channel i'm a die hard fan but the
last couple of weeks were disappointing
like that i was gone
what are you reading it's just a post
from the subreddit oh who cares
oh the new host okay fair enough was
supposed to launch it better be beyonce
at this point
yo um
rusty chips donated 50 canadian dollars
and said yo can i get a shout out for my
birthday from the boys shout out rusty
for 50 bucks i'll give you a shout out
your family happy birthday rusty rusty
big boy husty this is the big one
yeah they say they also say i wish the
crew was more involved how much more
involved can you be jesus you're
practically running the show at this
point you want me to leave
they're so they're so interesting and
have so much potential to run the show
even if
ethan isn't feeling well they want you
to take over the [ __ ] show look who
it is we have come say hi
we're wrapping it up right now
come say what up
this person is mad i took a week off
without big pants
i'm pretty sure i didn't even take like
a day off like all last year i saw that
pose but a lot of people were saying
what about ethan's
mentality i'm trying i want to be here i
might
live my whole my life and soul is for
you guys i mean what what more do you
want me here just put me down across and
[ __ ] you know just just
crucify me did you tell them you got an
assistant
i didn't
i mean we were doing stuff during that
week
yeah yeah of course it's not like we
were just chilling i mean we were
working the whole [ __ ] time
you want to do a pregnancy announcement
or you want to do it on friday just like
that no we got a whole we took them oh
we got a whole thing we got a whole
thing we're doing a gender reveal
anything else
this is the new thing we all have the
ability to uh
when ethan's going off the rails here's
spamming with her
i've slightly abused mine
av thinks people will be angry
but listen listen zach put in the
godfather sound i [ __ ] up
it's like one second i'll fix it i
promise i'm sorry now i'm being put on
the [ __ ] cross here
yeah we're all being put on the cross
i goofed up
can i do inconsistency i i'll die for
you
people are saying she's wearing pink
it's definitely a girl
her outfit has nothing to do you cannot
you cannot take any conclusions from
that nice
that's a necklace oh we gave you a shout
out for the article thank you we talked
about it
and we were i was talking about how
you're a strong independent woman but
nobody recognize you because you don't
go online about being a feminist icon
right
right right well said i thought what
martin needs to be said
all right well we're wrapping it up
thank you guys for watching any more
donuts to read uh
uh
a shitload really um
ten dollars from kelly the new teddy
fresh release on my birthday any chance
i could get a sweatshirt that is my
favorite collab i've been so excited for
it i love you guys been such a long time
fan i mean you shouldn't have donated
the ten dollars you should have spent
that at teddyfresh.com
is there a chance you can get us i don't
know
um samantha we love you papa bless
thank you thank you thank you carly can
we get ela's met gala takes up i mean
we're not gonna redo the whole segment
i wish you know we should have done it
on friday because she probably does have
she would have a lot more to say than us
yeah yeah very true
very true five dollars says we love elo
hey join the club
blue duncan club
rusty donated another 20 dollars and
said thanks boys you got it right happy
birthday again happy birthday rusty
live it up
all right thank you to everyone who
donated i'm sorry that we can't read
everyone's uh
uh donation but we love you all know
that and we'll be back on thursday
uh
forgive me for you know maybe i should
be doing two shows today i give and i
give and i give
maybe maybe uh you know thursday maybe i
should be doing the show i should be
doing show two shows every day
i i i sli is it is it okay with you if i
sleep eight hours maybe i should reduce
it to three so i could wake up earlier
and do another show
i thought they were gonna say like he's
late and that would be i'll be like okay
i'm late
but they're like no he took a week off
come on
you think i wanted to take a week off
oh jesus oh jesus
i'm not upset i understand i'm happy
that you're a fan of the show and that
makes me happy i'm doing my best though
okay gabish
come on
thank you
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you